the newest titles in the pokemon series
are the pokemon scarlet and pokemon
violet games
these titles will be open world rpgs a
first for the pokemon series
sprawling landscapes and vibrant towns
weave together to form the paldeya
region where your new adventure will
unfold
[Music]
these are the legendary pokemon corridon
and miraidon you'll rely on one of them
as a partner in your adventure climb on
and together you'll dash across grassy
fields
move across water
and glide through the sky
your partner can change forms as needed
while you explore every nook and cranny
of the region with them
you will be enrolling at a certain
academy as a student
and a special independent study project
awaits you the treasure hunt through it
you'll embark on a journey to find
treasure of your own here in paldea
three grand stories are waiting for you
one story will revolve around the
familiar gym battles
you'll go to eight pokemon gyms and aim
for the champion rank
in these games there is no set path you
must take when challenging the gyms
chart your very own course along victory
road
the other two stories you'll experience
hold many surprises and discoveries as
well
which story will you begin with how will
you progress through them it is all up
to you
professor sada and professor churro
research legends passed on in the paldea
region mr clavel is the director of the
academy you'll attend
and mr jacques is your homeroom teacher
who teaches biology
[Music]
you'll have your battle loving friend
nimona
[Music]
and you'll meet arvin an upperclassman
and a great cook
there's also penny a shy student in your
grade
there are gym leaders too
like grusha the ice type gym leader
the people you meet in paldea are sure
to enrich your adventures
[Music]
many different species of pokemon also
called the paldea region home
this pokemon is the paldayan regional
form of whooper
it lives on the land and covers its body
with a poisonous film
fido are delightfully squishy pokemon
that are smooth to the touch
and here's satin which has a large body
and a hard horn that can freeze its
surroundings
of course we also have the pokemon from
which you'll choose your first partner
sprightito fue coco
and quaxley
enjoy meeting lots of pokemon
and complete your pokedex as part of
your adventure
by using the union circle you can enjoy
co-op play with up to three friends
you can go look for pokemon you haven't
yet discovered
or even ride together to race across the
map
enjoy all the paldea region has to offer
with family and friends
[Music]
the terrastil phenomenon makes pokemon
shine like gems
[Music]
[Applause]
all pokemon in the paledaya region are
able to terrastilize which can provide a
boost to a pokemon's type and make its
moves stronger
some pokemon will change type when they
terrastilize
what type they become seems to depend on
that pokemon's terra type
[Music]
for example an eevee would typically
remain normal type after terrastilizing
but there could be eevee that become
grass or water type after terrastilizing
we hope you'll try to catch pokemon with
rare terror types
pokemon that have rare terror types are
more likely to appear in terra raid
battles
you can challenge terra pokemon in these
battles with up to three other trainers
this is a new kind of raid battle where
you can attack or heal with your own
timing without having to wait for your
allies
[Music]
try to cooperate with your allies to get
the upper hand in these battles
after you successfully defeat a tara
pokemon you'll get the opportunity to
catch it for yourself
[Music]
we've kept all the things you love about
pokemon while evolving the adventure you
can have in pokemon scarlet and pokemon
violet
we hope you look forward to the day you
set out on your adventure
you